because the pandemic Ubi started to be
talked about in a different way and
people started to see this as something
that was important that we actually
should have had before the pandemic
happened how how positively that would
have impacted everything to actually
have the floor underneath people
um you know we saw what happened when
people suddenly had to go through the
unemployment insurance systems state by
state and how some states were better
than others and we saw like massive Food
Bank lines and yet the grocery stores
had food like we could have it could
have been so much better if we had a Ubi
so I think people kind of felt that and
and see that now for themselves then we
come out of this and people start
complaining about there's a labor
shortage that nobody wants to work
anymore and they're blaming us and the
stimulus they're blaming it on
unemployment and everything
um but it really it's just kind of a
kind of amazing that we actually were
able to get where we are now as far is
getting the labor participation rate
back up but at the time as it's going
back up people are looking at a labor
shortage and they're just coming up all
kinds of stuff and then at that point
automation became like a joke like I
thought it was crazy how
um like you were even like the butt of
jokes of of being like Oh like Andrew
Yang said that you know everyone would
be out of a job and yet we can't find
anyone to work
so um like that was laughable and so a
lot of automation became like this joke
and then all of a sudden I feel that all
changed last November uh when when chat
GPT launched like that was a total Game
Changer in the entire conversation where
suddenly people were like oh my gosh
like this uh this is serious like AI can
do some magical things and so suddenly
we're in this world
where AI is just like
it's right there it's like it's
happening as we see it it's happening in
real time in a way that you know people
were making fun of even just you know a
year ago and one of the things I find
frustrating Scott is like people like
what do you mean automation like people
who can't find people to work you know
it's like well you know those two things
actually can happen at the same time
like you know companies can be investing
good jillions of dollars and automating
uh various roles and you have a hard
time getting people to show up for job
extra job why particularly if those jobs
are frankly punitive or undercompensated
or whatever the heck the the situation
is so
um I agree with you that the
conversation definitely changed when
chat GPT came online everyone was like
wait a minute uh this thing can do what
I do you know this thing this thing
scores an 88 percentile on the bar exam
it's like better than you know most
attorneys probably manage so for me the
trend has just been ongoing the whole
time I mean even during covid when
people were sent home I I saw one survey
that said that almost half of companies
said they were investing more in
automation so it's been interesting this
is just like recently just in the last
like let's say week or so you've seen
like a lot of companies
um starting to like even clamp down on
their API usage and saying you know I
don't we don't want
um these large models to actually be
using our data anymore you should pay us
kind of thing and so there's like these
walls coming up and so you know on the
one hand you can think well okay
um
put up those walls and and make sure
that your users you know get the money
for it but we all know that's not going
to happen
like these walls if they do that they're
just going to make sure that the company
itself gets the money it's going to help
profits it's going to help shareholders
it's not going to go down to the users
users still don't get anything and I
think that it's important to communicate
Ubi as an AI dividend you know in this
where we are now like I I think part of
the barrier to Ubi is people thinking
you know oh like people are going to be
left with nothing uh except for this
like poverty floor level you know basic
income and that's all that they'll get
and you know speaking of it as a
dividend as you did in your campaign you
know it gets people to see that you know
people think of a dividend as the better
the company does the better I do and so
you know if you have a like a true
dividend let's say it's tied to GDP per
capita as productivity increases as AI
is able to become more more capable than
the floor Rises and that floor can be
seen as something that people you know
deserve that it's earned it's an earned
dividend it's not welfare it's not
something that somehow limits them it's
something that is supplementary to
everything else that they do and is
enabling everything that they do and
continues to increase as the the nation
improves
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you